in this segment we derive and discuss
the weak law of large numbers it is a
rather simple result but plays a central
role within probability theory the
setting is as follows we start with some
probability distribution that has a
certain mean and variance which we
assume to be finite we then draw
independent random variables out of this
distribution so that these x i's are
independent and identically distributed
iid for short what's going on here is
that we are carrying out a long
experiment during which all of these
random variables are drawn once we have
drawn n of these random variables we can
calculate the average of the values that
have been obtained and this gives us the
so called sample mean
notice that the sample mean is a random
variable because it is a function of
random variables it should be
distinguished from the true mean mu
which is the expected value of the x i's
which is a number it is not random and
mu is some kind of average over all the
possible outcomes of the random variable
X I the sample mean is the simplest and
most natural way for trying to estimate
the true mean and the weak law of large
numbers will provide some support to
this notion let us now look at the
properties of the sample mean let us
calculate its expectation by the way
this object here involves two different
kinds of averaging the sample mean
averages over the values observed during
one long experiment whereas the
expectation averages over all possible
outcomes of this experiment the
expectation is some kind of theoretical
average because we do not get to observe
all the possible outcomes of this
experiment but the sample mean is
something that we actually calculate on
the basis of our observed
in any case the expected value of the
sample mean by linearity it is the
expected value of the numerator divided
by the denominator using linearity once
more the expected value of a sum is the
sum of the expected values and since
each one of those expected values is
equal to MU we obtain n times mu divided
by n which leaves us with mu so the
theoretical average the expected value
of the sample mean is equal to the true
mean let us now calculate the variance
of the sample mean the variance of a
random variable divided by a number is
the variance of that random variable
divided by the square of that number now
since the x i's are independent the
variance is the sum of the variances and
therefore we obtain n times the variance
of each one of them and after we
simplify this leaves us with Sigma
squared over n we are now in a position
to apply the chebyshev inequality the
chebyshev inequality tells us that the
distance of a random variable from its
mean being larger than a certain number
has a probability that's bounded above
by the variance of the random variable
of interest divided by the square of the
number that we have here we have already
calculated the variance and so this
quantity is Sigma squared over n times
epsilon squared and now if we consider
epsilon as a fixed number and let n go
to infinity then what we obtain is a
limiting value of zero
so the probability of falling far from
the mean diminishes to zero as we draw
more and more samples that's exactly
what the weak law of large number tells
us if we fix any particular epsilon
which is a positive constant the
probability that the sample mean falls
away from the true mean by more than
Epsilon
that probability becomes smaller and
smaller and converges to zero as n goes
to infinity
let us now interpret the weak law of
large numbers as I already hinted we
have to think in terms of one long
experiment and during that experiment we
draw several independent random
variables drawn from the same
distribution one way of thinking about
those random variables is that each one
of them is equal to the mean the true
mean plus some measurement noise which
is a term that has zero expected value
and all of these noises are independent
so we have a collection of noisy
measurements and then we take those
measurements and form the average of
them what the weak law of large numbers
tells us is that the sample mean is
unlikely to be far off from the true
mean and by far off we mean at least
epsilon distance away so the sample mean
is in some ways a good way of estimating
the true mean if n is large enough then
we have high confidence that the sample
mean gives us a value that's close to
the true mean as a special case let us
consider a probabilistic model in which
will repeat independently many times the
same experiment there's a certain event
a associated with that experiment that
has a certain probability and each time
that we carry out the experiment we use
an indicator variable to indicate
whether the outcome was inside the event
or outside the event so X I is 1
a occurs and it is zero otherwise the
expected value of the X is the true mean
in this case is equal to the number P in
this particular example the sample mean
just counts how many times the event a
occurred out of the n experiments that
we carried out so it's the frequency
with which the event a has occurred and
we call it the empirical frequency of
event a what the weak law of large
numbers tells us is that the empirical
frequency will be close to the
probability of that event in this sense
it reinforces or justifies the
interpretation of probabilities as
frequencies